avant il a vendu 2 milliards de la
cinquième on lui remette son disque
d'iridium nous recevrons ludwig van
beethoven
est ce que vous avez fait un bon voyage
une goutte rise que faisiez-vous au
moment où je vous ai téléporté dans
cette émission
que pensez-vous de l'hommage qui vous a
été rendu par le par le rock'n'roll roll
over beethoven
on peut regretter un petit un petit bout
de là je pense qu'on va lui faire
entendre et puis je vais monde je manque
920 des ouais voilà on va faire comme ça
[Musique]
m
bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors on leur bar lounge un bar
absolument
bon il comprend il entend rien de ce que
je lui dis y'a qu'a dit le dos est ce
qu'on pourrait trouver un moyen pour je
puisse me faire entendre de ce set est
en vérité c'est en allemand non je n'y
étais pas un sonotone
ça tombe chance mais ici c'est parce que
c'est regarder venir mais je crois qu'il
a peur on ne sait pas ce que c'est je
prie kenzi deutsch demandez lui ce qui
pendait kenzy doc baltaguia nevis nous
coûte une vaste invesco von roll over
beethoven elle ne comprend rien et vous
verrez c'est pas grave essayez le
langage de son but face à l'espérance
ça ne marche pas et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu